so we're into the the chaos if you like
of FTX uh which Sam creates because he
decides that all crypto exchanges are
flawed and therefore he makes his own
there is a delicious description which
you must give us of a phone call between
Sam bankman freed and Anna winter at the
height of his celebrity well well when
when this when FTX is making vast sums
of money does everybody know who Anna
winter is yeah yeah I think so so Sam
didn't so and and uh and and which was
so I will take you to this I'm going
have to give you I have to give a little
context because I for me the Delight is
partly the context I had just started
can I watch he says yes watching just
means following around um we I go to the
Bahamas he says oh we got we're going to
the we changed our minds it's not the
Bahamas this week it's the Super Bowl
this is February of 2000 of last year we
get to we get to Beverly Hills
California and he says I got a bunch of
things that they want me to do but I
don't know which I'm going to do there a
long there a menu of celebrities that
wanted to spend time with him and he was
trying to figure out which celebrities
including the CEO of Goldman sack
because everybody's at the Super Bowl
and he says there's the first thing is
this party he says it's I got this
address and I got this name but I don't
know this guy and I don't and he says
they're going to be all these important
people there but I don't know Sam's has
a small Entourage who are continually
freaking out that someone's going to
kidnap Sam because he's the most kidnapp
person in the world he is he's
completely oblivious to what's going on
around him he's in shorts and a t-shirt
and unarmed and and has no muscles and
and and has $22 billion worth of crypto
or whatever he has enough cryp and
crypto is like the best Ransom so they
say you can't go to this party if you
don't know who this is he says I think I
want to go and so they follow behind him
and wait outside the house in Beverly
Hills where the party is in case he's
being kidnapped and I go in with him
I've never heard of this person either
the man's name is Michael keas he was a
former Hollywood agent we walk we walk
through the house into the backyard
where the party is and there may be 60
people there this is a short list of who
was there Hillary Clinton four
Kardashians Leo DiCaprio Chris Rock
owners of two NFL football teams ktie
Perry Kate Hudson
Orlando Bloom it's like an average
Saturday night at my house Jeff you know
what I've always thought Jeff Bezos Jeff
Bezos so it went it was everybody the
mega the wattage was incredible so this
is the first so and within about 30
minutes the clusters of people you see
the conversations everybody's around Sam
they all want to talk to him at the end
of it this is funny at the end of it the
host uh who figured out who I was comes
over and says you really I really want
you to meet Hillary Clinton I'd never
met Hillary Clinton so I went out she's
leaving she's very sweet she fun to talk
to I go on the front lawn there she is
in the dark and I all by herself and I
say hi and she says uh she she looks at
me and she
says what are you doing here and and cuz
I'm not A-list and and and I said well
this is odd I've just met this person
I'm just trailing around behind him
because I think there might be a book
and she goes the guy with the
and I said yes how did you know she said
I talked to him I thought he's a
character for you so but anyway so we've
just come from this back to the hotel
next morning he says I got some meeting
I don't know who this person is it's a
zoom I said can I just sit in and watch
because now I know I want to see
everything and and he and I go into his
it's say me and him in his hotel room he
doesn't sleep in his hotel rooms so this
is there are many bizarre things but
he'll be in a place for three nights and
you don't know where he slept I think
the dumpster but just if he has
something about he you know what it is
he he's incredibly uncomfortable
sleeping alone like he needs Comfort
it's why he sleeps on a bean bag in the
office he he can't something whatever's
going on in his mind so on the screen
zoom and a win tour and he he does not
know who she is he doesn't know what the
purpose of the meeting is he doesn't
know well the purpose of the meeting is
can Sam bman freed pay for the whole Met
Gala that's the purpose of the meeting
because he'll pay for everything else
why not that and she comes on the screen
and she is dressed to the nine she's got
those size of hair coming down around
her chin she's like ready to kill and
and gorgeous you know she looks great
she's well prepared he's playing
storybook brawl which is his video game
and whenever she comes on the screen he
blacks her out and the video game pops
up so like she's she's talking and and
mon minur are killing are killing dwarfs
and and and trees with axes are coming
in and like you know weapons are
appearing on the screen and people are
dying and exploding and and and you're
hearing her talk about the Met Gala and
and there's seven minutes in when he
hits a button and the W Wikipedia entry
for the mech Galla comes up so he can
figure out what the hell she's talking
about and and he's doing I watched him
do this he's doing this with her this is
what he was doing on live television
when he would be interviewed by
Bloomberg TV it was like he and he he
had tricks it took him about one tenth
of his brain to have a conversation with
with Anna winter
and what he would do other other part of
his brain was either reading about who
she was or playing his game and um what
he'd do is he'd say you ask me a
question he'd say that's a really good
question it's a really good question let
me think about that for a minute you
know meanwhile the minutor is killing
the tree and he comes off and then he
thinks for a minute and he says some
boilerplate thing or and and he did this
thing this is where I first became aware
of this tick and then I had to trace it
back to actually it was a theory of how
to go through life with Sam bankman
freed he never said no he never
disagreed he agreed with everything she
said every opinion every suggestion
every proposal it was yep that's a great
idea that's really interesting she left
that call thinking she was never going
to have to put on she the Met Galla was
going to be paid for for the next 20
years she would and afterwards he gets
off it and I said I look at him he look
he's such a schlub you know like you
can't imagine that rolling up a red
carpet with Anna wior I I said Ian I
didn't know his I didn't know then his
principled objection to actually
dressing well that he had a whole
argument about a people spending way too
much time caring about their appearances
I knew nothing about that but I just
looked at him and I said like do you
realize what you just agreed to do like
you want to go he said I don't want to
go he says I I have to think about this
I said do you know what it is kind of
you know sort of and and it was clear he
had not even started the process of
deciding whether he was going to give
her a nickel or go she thinks he's going
to be here date and she he's going to
pay for the whole thing and of course it
created enormous mess down the road
where he says he's not going but the
whole thing about giving people the
impression that he just was agreeing
with him he said that that's something
he learned right right as he was coming
out of Jan Street actually he was after
the Schism but when he had to start to
be a real social creature like his
exchange to people which was such an
alien thing he realiz he said what did
he say people like he said I found that
people like you a lot more if you agree
with them and so it became the algorithm
the algorithm was just agree with people
and I'm sorry I'm going on here a bit
but I I tell one of the things that came
up over and over and over and I don't
ever say it in the book but a shrewd
reader will pick it up is that what
we're watching here feels a little like
a foreshadowing
of AI dystopia where you you've given
instructions to a machine and it is but
you've not given much in the way of
nuance to the instruction and the
Machine does what it does with the
instructions in ways you never imagined
so you say uh you say uh get me a uh a
reservation at the Dorchester restaurant
I assume they still have a restaurant
and you don't tell it how to do it and
it goes and finds that the doorchester
restaurant's fully booked so it starts
murdering people who has reservations at
the door
that's what we're watching here and and
and but but you you take him at face
value I mean by this stage he was giving
huge amounts of money away I don't take
him at face value well you got
I don't take him at face value at all
well okay so let me let me ask a
question rather than making an assertion
is he is he sincere did you believe in
him how much of this was genuine could
anyone be that otherworldly who had
chosen to live in a multi-billion dollar
complex in the Bahamas
so so so the you don't appreciate how
great this story is unless you
appreciate how deeply wetted to the
effective altruism stuff he was it was
not for show it it was that so the the M
this condo keeps coming up because it's
like the one example of
material he didn't buy them in the first
place his his but he didn't seem to care
about happened to the money if he
actually cared about the he needed there
was a reason he bought these when you go
to Bahamas and you need to move move 150
people from Hong Kong overnight into the
Bahamas who don't want to go to the
Bahamas you better give them a nice
place to live and there wasn't a whole
lot of other you try to buy that kind of
property and it also he thought it was
just going to hold his value he he was
not I I I said this on television the
other day and I got in trouble for it
but it's absolutely true if you gave Sam
bankman freed a
choice uh spend the rest of his life in
jail with an internet connection or
spend the rest of his life in that
Bahamas cond without one he'd much
rather be in jail that that that that's
not what gets him off what gets him off
is the information flow and the he was
the material stuff he's kind of he's he
is people around him were not
indifferent to it nobody by around him
was indifferent to it but that's that
part's real the effective altruist part
the the wetted to it it's his it was his
identity so that part's real now they're
part they're problematic Parts but you
got to accept that's real if you want to
understand this person in the story okay
couple more for me and I I'm Keen to
open up to the floor really already I
thought we were just getting going is it
because I said no oh no I'm
allowed to argue back right of course
you are the what you got in your brain
right now is partly a result of crypto
Twitter it's like noise coming in that's
just
like I don't know why this world does
not is so threatened by an actual a
portrayal of the actual person but let
me ask a question of you and and how you
relate to him he isn't like a lot of the
contrarians or oddballs that perhaps
you've written about in the past if we
think think about Billy Bean in
Moneyball for instance you know use data
and analytics to build a winning
baseball team was out on his own out on
a limb similarly Michael bur in The Big
Short Sam bankman freed doesn't fit into
that mold has he taken you by surprise
he's not quite the sort of Underdog the
hero I would never you know I get other
people misdescribed my books uh if you
look at the characters in The Big Short
some of them quite problem IC characters
and so I don't I'm not looking for a
hero ever that's it's the last thing
from my mind if I'm looking when I'm
looking at characters when you say and
I've gotten more character-driven what
am I looking for fun is one of the
things I'm looking for but is it fun 8
billion dollar is is Miss appears to be
missing people are in C so it's getting
more interesting than that you say that
8 billion how much do you think is
actually missing I don't know no you
don't know so here I'll tell you how
much is actually missing and this is
where it's getting really odd so the
bankruptcy people have show have have
said that there's $8.6 billion do in
missing customer deposits and that as of
June they had located 7.3 billion and it
wasn't like clawbacks it was just there
7.3 billion so it's 1.3 billion that's
missing plus and there said there's
still more to be
number will you hold on this is where
today today the prosecution the
prosecution sent a motion to the court
saying can please not talk about the
possibility the customers are all going
to get their money back and and and that
in particular can we you going to let me
finish I am you do you care I need to
let on do you care how much is missing I
think what I care about is the fact that
at the very least now I do think it's
important I think at the very least he's
irresponsible I'm not saying he's not
irresponsible I'm saying it's just
different than you think so well I'm
going to finish my thought this is where
it gets very cool so he bought he bought
to the outrage of his colleagues TW a
20% stake in an AI company called
anthropic along with several hundred
other Venture Capital Investments this
this stake looks like it's now valued
well the company when he bought it was
valued at a couple of billion dollars
the U the company now looks like it's
valued at $30 billion and the
prosecution does not want the jury to
know that my God they're going to get
their money back now it's may be
irrelevant from a legal point of view
but from a social point of view and from
the I'm a creditor I had money on his
exchange I care about that so I think
it's I think it's relevant and may speak
to intent um as for my like what I look
for the number one thing is are they
going to teach us about the world and
are they one themselves good teachers
and explainers and he's a very good
explainer and teacher but are two is
there are there circumstances revealing
us to us things about the world and the
reason I didn't write a word about this
of this book I wasn't even sure I had a
book uh until nove until it all fell
apart but I didn't write a word about
till January so it's not like there are
words in this book that got made up
before it all went bad um that that I
was it's the Sam bman freed shaped hole
this is a bizarre situation he goes from
nothing to having $22 billion in 18
months the whole world reshapes itself
around him in ways that are telling you
about the world e and then when it all
collapses all the people who were with
him turn on him all the media that was
with him turn on him the and he's
continuing to light up the world in an
interesting way so that's what appeals
to me it isn't is he a hero is can he
tell us things okay one final one for me
which is really important um which is
how did this fraud happen what was the
fraud the alleged fraud so uh so the um
Everybody agrees on this this is like
the defend all the lawyers in the court
will agree on this that uh roughly $10
billion of customer deposits that were
meant to be in Cold Storage on this on
FTX The Exchange were in fact in his
that that hedge fund he starts as his
first business Alam research which is in
a little Hut beside the exchange in the
Bahamas and the the question is there's
not even much question about how it got
there so there were two mechanisms um
the first was when FTX began this is
going to probably bore everybody should
I do this to do it as briefly is it is
important to
understand I'll try to be quick so um
when it started FTX couldn't get bank
accounts not because it was illegal but
because Banks were rightly very
suspicious about banking crypto
operations they had banked Alam partly
because Alam had disguised it was a
crypto operation so if you wanted to
send your pounds into FTX so you could
buy some crypto the bank account you
sent it to was Alam and 8.8 billion
piles up this way before FTX gets its
bank accounts then that mechanism for
that money piling up in Alam vanishes
the other thing that happens is um in
the very beginning of the exchange
um so every other customer on FTX is is
not allowed really to put the exchange
at risk this was have been a problem in
crypto these exchanges have gone down
over and over because customers come in
make big bets they Lo they lose and they
don't have the money to cover the bets
and the exchange and the customers end
up covering the bets and whole exchanges
go down for this reason one of the
ironically the big selling point for FTX
was they had built a a risk engine that
made sure that okay if you riddle a come
in and you put down 10 quid to buy 100
quid worth of bitcoin that before you
lose your 10 quid in your Bitcoin trade
they take you out of the trade so
nobody's going to lose money they
switched the engine off for Alam Traders
so Alam had the right to lose basically
unlimited sums and there's two or three
billion dollar that get into Alam
essentially borrowings from Alam that
through that mechanism so those are the
two mechanisms for the then the question
is and this we're not going to go into
it's going to take forever but the law
the the details of the how and the why
and the spirit in which they did it
which the trial will reveal but yes look
as you can tell I could keep talking
probably until tomorrow morning so but I
want to throw it open to you guys just
to remind you roing mics down here uh in
the hall downstairs two fixed mics up
there downstairs when the mic comes to
you if you can stand up when you ask a
question if you're watching online then
please please type your questions into
the box below and uh we will I will
definitely ask them I can see them here
in front of me I'm going to go yes
there's a lady there and I'll take what
I'll do is I'll take three so I'll take
you and there's a gentleman behind you
so go with that first go go hello hi um
so sorry I'm taking a step back from
this specific story but I'm I didn't
expect to be the first one to be
selected but I'm more curious about your
writing process in general and you have
been so successful in telling the
stories of real people in a compelling
way to the level that they have been
adopted for uh movies what do you think
is in your book and in your style of a
storytelling that Mak
makes your story so compelling okay and
there's a gentleman behind you there
yeah you were mentioning that it looks
like possibly all of the creditors will
get their money back they may they might
they might um what about the the
Charities the organizations the long-
termist and effective altruist
organizations to whom they had promised
billions of dollars there were projects
that were already gearing up to having
been funded I'm just wondering if you
know what might happen to those cuz some
of them are completely
done for yeah so effective alist
organizations that might have got money
that will no longer and what is it do
you think that makes your writing your
books so compelling you what order you
want me to take them any order you like
it's hard to remember both at once but
all right uh so um so let's the second
one because that's a the the the effect
I'll start with that the effective
altruist um uh the the donations so
there's an interesting intellectual
exercise that needs to be done inside
the bankruptcy that has not been done
and that John Ray the person running it
said would be would be done but it
hasn't been done um told me he would be
done and that in order to so there two
problems with the people who've been
given money people who've actually been
given money face the prospect of having
it clawed back by the bankruptcy that's
one kind of problem and then there
people who thought they were going to
get money and the money doesn't show I
don't think it's I don't think that
second is actually billions but there
are some I've heard from them and that's
just sad and they're not going to get
any money they it was if it it was
promised or it was hoped for and it's
not going to be there but the the
curiouser pile is oh you already got he
gave away I don't know three or $400
million and did it in a much of it in a
very odd way um they they looked at the
philanthropic model and said it's kind
of busted like that huge in most
philanthropies huge amounts of money
just go to sustaining the philan thy to
bureaucracy costs and and to vetting
proposals and on subjects that you don't
know that much about so what they did is
they had their buckets they were
interested in they were interested in
mostly existential risk to humanity but
it was pandemic prevention it was
artificial intelligence what whatever
the buckets were they went out to
individuals who they knew understood who
were Specialists and set essentially you
might get an out of the blue this email
from FTX here's a million dollars
give it away in the best way possible
just do it and and you can do it however
you want and we're not going to monitor
it and just tell us what you did so we
can just track to see how effective this
was so there were several hundred people
who got that email and gave that money
away but but means that the gifts were
in pretty small amounts and I don't
think worth the while of the bankruptcy
to try to go get so I don't think
they're going to claw it back but the
intellectual exercise they have to
engage in to clawback is to prove that
when the money was given away FTX was
actually bankrupt and the the question
is when was FTX bankrupt it it it
certainly wasn't bankrupt in February of
last year it was it there was there was
Triple or double the number of customer
deposits there there was so there's some
moment either when crypto collapses or
maybe it's not even till November of
last year when you could actually prove
that it was bankrupt and if they can't
prove it was bankrupt they can't claw
back so I I don't the only people who
given back money people who are
embarrassed by it the money the
politicians kind of they've been a bit
of that but they don't have to give the
money back and I would love to see
someone fight it because I think you're
going to probably get
to the argument is going to be it's
going to be somewhere it's going to be
pretty late in the day in FTX is life
before it's actually bankrupt uh writing
process like why do you want me to ask
explain why they get made into movies or
just why I like my books sell uh the
both kind of so the process
is I asked myself this because I'm a
curious creature as a writer I don't
most writers had a sense of themselves
as writers pretty young and I had no
sense of myself as a writer until I got
out of college and nobody ever said I
swear to you no one ever saw promise in
me no one no English teacher said oh you
really have talent you really should I
had no Walter Mish like fantasy nothing
so never wrote for a school new
newspaper so it's strange that my life
has taken the course it's
taken what happened in my case was I
became when I was a senior in college
wholly absorbed with a book length
thesis I had to write and it turned out
very very well intellectually not very
well literarily so poorly literarily
that when I asked my professor what do
you think of the writing he said put it
this way never try to make a living at
it but I I I did I did try to make a
living at it and and I did it because it
was the one thing I'd ever done that
could be construed as work that during
which I lost track of time and it was
here in London I was living up in
Hamstead and our St John's Wood first
but then Hamstead and then I would I
would I don't know why I had to need to
make that distinction but the but but
but they all quite different yeah I know
they're different but but I can remember
hours would pass I'd write some artic
article that would be rejected by some
place and hours would pass and I
wouldn't know it had passed I also
noticed that when I wrote letters to
people in a more in a real
self-conscious way like here's what's
going on in London now they would get
passed around like you know I would come
home go home to New Orleans and people
would come up and say I read that letter
you wrote your mother it's all over the
place it's funny and I thought well
people want people want to read me they
they will they will read me um so I had
and I think it I think to the extent
there was any ability it was some kind
of voice on the page that I can't
explain and that would never have been
identified by um Academia at any school
at any point because they don't ask for
voice they ask for you know a thesis
statement and a blah blah blah and you
never yourself in school but when I was
myself on the page it somehow worked and
I don't want to know why it just like
works and I don't want to stop um but
for the subjects like why the things
work I this this is this is going to
sound like but I think it's
true I'm basically an incredibly lazy
person like left I'm an you know an
object at rest will remain at rest I
will remain at rest longer than any
other object that I just don't I don't
have an Impulse to work so for something
to get my attention to the point where
I'll get off my ass and actually do
something about it it's got to be really
exciting I get really you can tell I get
really worked up about the subjects so
I'm it's passing through filter to get
to the point where I'm going to write
about it I'm not going to just write a
book to write a book right now I may
never write another book again like I
don't care if I I would like to but I I
don't care that much I'm prepared that
that's I've never found a subject that
will excite me again and I won't do it
ever again the fact that like I it has
to Rouse me I think gets me to a place
with the reader where it Rouses the
reader too I also think that as for not
as it's it's a this genre I work in is
particularly American genre it's heavily
heavily reported like people think I
just have an opinion about Sam bman
freed I don't have an opinion or or my
opinion is earned anyway it's a year and
a half of hundreds of hours of immersion
not just with him but everything around
him and I don't I wouldn't if you'd
asked me after six months write a book I
couldn't have done it I this is a funny
thing the day before FTX collapsed I was
with a very famous film director who has
become a kind of friend who I use as a
sounding board for story because I
admire his story his story instincts and
I said to him I got this problem I've
spent a year and two months marinating
in this world and I describ Sam the
character I described a bunch of scenes
I said I've got all this stuff but I
don't have a story and I can't figure
out why I don't have a story and he said
you don't have a story because you don't
have a third act there's no ending to
this and I said that's exactly that's
exactly right and it's also right that I
don't know how to start it unless I Know
How It Ends like I've had books where I
know the last sentence I knew the last
like the last words of this book before
I wrote the first words of the book
sometimes it changes but sometimes I
actually am navigating to a point I know
and I know where to navigate to so I was
prepared at that moment not to write the
book and uh it wasn't until I was
absolutely like had it in the bag and
was sure that I even bother to sit down
and write the book and I think that
helps I I think that like the walkway
ability like don't do it unless it
actually feels right as a story really
helps with the with the readers and
probably with the movies too because it
gives them some
structure